Jedna oblast, kde by kvantové výpočty mohly zlepšit strojové učení,
souvisí s jádrovými funkcemi neboli
jádrovými maticemi – pojďme si vysvětlit, co to jsou,
a proč je potřebujeme. K tomu si připomeneme
tři věci: proč se skalární součin objevuje ve strojovém učení,
proč problémy strojového učení zahrnují vyšší dimenze,
a co jsou jádrové funkce.
Připomeň si, že skalární součin neboli vnitřní součin
reálných n-rozměrných vektorů a
a b je dán součinem velikosti vektoru a,
velikosti vektoru b a kosinu úhlu theta mezi nimi.
To je ekvivalentní vynásobení
každé složky a odpovídající složkou
b a jejich součtu. Všimni si, že pokud jsou vektory
přibližně ortogonální – například když a
má nulové složky tam, kde b má velké,
skalární součin je malý. To odpovídá
situaci, kdy se theta blíží pí/2.
Podobně, pokud má a záporné složky tam, kde b
má kladné složky,
tedy vektory míří
přibližně opačným směrem
a theta je blízko pí,
výsledek skalárního součinu může být
záporný. A nakonec, pokud má a velké složky tam, kde b
má taky velké složky stejného znaménka,
takže vektory jsou přibližně rovnoběžné a theta je blízko nuly,
skalární součin bude velký
a kladný. Takže je docela přirozené očekávat, že skalární součin
bude užitečnou mírou podobnosti
datových bodů. Ne všechna n-rozměrná data
jdou snadno oddělit v (n−1)-rozměrném řezu –
tedy přímkou, rovinou nebo nadrovinou.
Pokud data nejsou v n dimenzích dobře oddělitelná,
můžeme datové body vnořit do vyšších dimenzí,
řekněme m dimenzí, kde m
je větší než n. Tomu se říká mapování příznaků,
označované jako x jdoucí na phi(x), kde
phi(x) je zobrazení z n-rozměrných reálných čísel do
m-rozměrných reálných čísel.
Nejsnáze si to lze představit, když
ohýbáme jednorozměrná data do
dvou dimenzí, nebo bereme dvourozměrná data
a vkládáme je do tří dimenzí.
V praxi ale data často vkládáme do prostorů s tisíci
nebo dokonce miliony dimenzí.
Skalární součin třírozměrných vektorů oproti skalárnímu součinu
dvourozměrných vektorů je zanedbatelný rozdíl,
ale skalární součin miliónrozměrných vektorů
se stane naprosto neproveditelným
pro velké datové sady.
Proto lidé přišli s chytrým trikem:
co kdybys použil projekci
do vyšších dimenzí ve velmi specifickém tvaru,
takovou, že skalární součiny vektorů ve
vyšších dimenzích jsou jednoduchou funkcí
nízkodimenzionálních vektorů? Tedy najdeme zobrazení
z dat x do vysokodimenzionálního phi(x),
takové, že vnitřní součin v
prostoru příznaků je dán
jednoduchou funkcí v nízkodimenzionálních datech.
Tato funkce k se nazývá jádrová funkce.
Ideálně bychom chtěli, aby tato jádrová funkce
byla funkcí samotného nízkodimenzionálního
vnitřního součinu – to by nám dalo
to nejlepší z obou světů: velmi vysokodimenzionální prostor příznaků,
ale levný a snadno počitatelný vnitřní součin.
Na první pohled nemusí být
zřejmé, že to vůbec jde. Podívejme se na
jeden jednoduchý příklad ve velmi nízkých dimenzích.
Uvažuj toto konkrétní mapování příznaků – zobrazuje
třírozměrný vektor do
devítidimenzionálního prostoru. Ukáže se,
že vnitřní součin v devítidimenzionálním prostoru příznaků
je jednoduše dán vnitřním součinem v původním
třírozměrném prostoru na druhou. Takže vnitřní součin
v zobrazeném prostoru pomocí funkcí phi
by vyžadoval výpočet každé z
devíti souřadnic pro
první vektor a devíti pro
druhý, a pak samotný vnitřní součin, což je
dalších devět součinů a součet –
celkem dvacet osm operací.
Jádrová funkce vyžaduje tři součiny
a dva součty, což odpovídá pouhým čtyřem operacím.
To bylo pro zobrazení třírozměrného datového bodu do
devítidimenzionálního prostoru příznaků.
Je snadné vidět, že to může být velmi výhodné
pro velmi velké prostory.
Jádrová funkce je typicky spojitá funkce,
kterou můžeš aplikovat na libovolný vektor v datové sadě.
Jádrové funkce ale používáme tak, že bereme
dvojice datových bodů z naší sady
jako argumenty. Aplikování jádrové funkce na
každou dvojici datových bodů v sadě
dá symetrickou matici zvanou jádrová
matice. Typ jádrové funkce, který použiješ, závisí na
tvém problému. Takže pro shrnutí:
popis podobnosti vektorů v datových sadách
často vyžaduje vnitřní součiny. Vnitřní součiny ve
velmi vysokodimenzionálních prostorech příznaků jsou nákladné,
proto používáme mapování příznaků odpovídající
určitým speciálním jádrovým funkcím,
které výpočet zefektivní.
Toto omezení na speciální jádrové funkce ale
omezuje, jaká zobrazení do prostoru příznaků lze
provést efektivně. To
nám může bránit v dobrém oddělení dat.
Kdyby jen existoval jiný způsob…
A tady nastupují kvantové výpočty.
Velmi vysokodimenzionální mapování příznaků odpovídající
jádrovým funkcím lze provést
na kvantovém počítači v kvantovém jádrovém estimátoru.
Jádrová matice k se vypočítá
a od té chvíle může klasický algoritmus strojového učení
dokončit práci. Jeden datový bod x1
se načte a zobrazí, pak
se načte druhý x2
a zobrazí. Protože vnitřní součin dvou kvantových stavů
souvisí s pravděpodobností měření,
můžeme odhadnout vnitřní součin dvou zobrazených
datových bodů dostatečně mnoha měřeními
výsledného circuit. Tímto způsobem nám circuit
může říct o vnitřním součinu
v libovolném vysokodimenzionálním prostoru, který circuit dokáže modelovat,
aniž bychom klasicky kdy počítali vnitřní součin nebo
jádrovou funkci. Existuje mnoho způsobů,
jak tyto metody přizpůsobit a vylepšit,
a skutečně jsou neustále navrhovány
a testovány nové metody. Doufáme, že tento
přehled ti pomohl zasadit do kontextu
využití kvantových výpočtů
ve strojovém učení,
zejména u metod zahrnujících jádra.